Au début j'avais pensé vous emmener à la campagne, pas très loin hein, moins de 100 km.
Enfin, 100 km, après huit semaines de confinement,
c'est un petit peu une expédition.
C'est peut-être un peu beaucoup là...
Et puis, en faisant le tour de mon jardin, je me suis dit
qu'on allait y rester encore un peu.
Il s'y déroule en ce moment un phénomène extraordinaire.
Vous entendez ce bourdonnement  ?
Ça butine, c'est comme ça depuis plusieurs jours.
C'est un céanothe, certains disent aussi : un lilas de Californie.
Il a un peu souffert l'été dernier avec la canicule mais bon, il est quand même fait de belles fleurs.
Les abeilles l'adores, elles viennent en priorité sur cet arbuste.
C'est normal.
Elles sont attirées par le bleu ! Depuis une quinzaine d'années, on sait que c'est la seule couleur à laquelle elles sont sensibles !
Ce qui est très étonnant, c'est que cette couleur n'est pas la plus répandue dans le monde végétal.
Si vous regardez bien autour de vous, vous verrez davantage de fleurs
oranges, jaunes ou blanches que de fleurs bleues.
Pendant longtemps, les scientifiques se sont demandés comment les abeilles
repéraient les fleurs d'une
autre couleur que le bleu.
Maintenant ils savent, en observant
de très très près des pétales,
ils ont constaté qu'ils étaient striés. À cause de ces stries, la lumière est
diffractée. Les différentes couleurs qui composent la lumière blanche sont séparées les unes des autres.
On ne le voit pas ! Les abeilles, oui, pour vous donner une petite idée de ce qu'elles voient...
on obtient le même effet avec un CD en jouant avec la lumière.
Eh bien cette irisation des pétales
génère un halo de lumière
autour des fleurs, qui contient du bleu, qui attire le regard des abeilles
qui se précipitent vers des fleurs dont elles ignorent la couleur réelle !
Enfin réelle, la couleur
que nous ne nous voyons !
On y retourne ?
Elles se régalent, elles se gavent de
nectar et font le plein de pollen
qu'elles rassemblent sur leurs pattes arrière, et surtout, en allant de fleur en fleur, elles déposent le pollen de l'une
sur le pistil de l'autre et participent ainsi activement, mais involontairement,
à la pollinisation. Donc à la reproduction des plantes.
On estime que 35 % de ce que nous mangeons est lié à l'activité des insectes !
Et il y a du monde là-dedans, pas que des abeilles domestiques. Il a aussi des bourdons
et des abeilles
sauvages.
Elles sont plus petites
que leurs cousines domestiques,
elles sont solitaires et vivent dans des tiges creuses,
ou sous l'écorce d'arbres morts, ou encore dans les anfractuosités de sol ou de la roche.
Du coup, je leur ai
installé un petit hôtel !
Elles on le droit,
moins de 100 km !
Allez, à très bientôt pour une nouvelle
capsule de déconfiné, lungo !